[Music]
if I that you are alive because of what
you brought on that plane
the hell are you welcome to pro digium
we recognize you salmon contain and
destroy evil
what you have released they don't like
anything with other faced
she did something to me
I know you did not
sacrifices must be made
where that leave me with the choice
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever them come safely hidden for
2,000 years if we're gonna turn its
produced neck
the hieroglyph said she remained
dominant chosen to be Egypt's next queen
but her thirst for power led her down a
darker path one that had to be stopped
because of your actions at this ancient
power has returned
[Music]
you are alive because you're chosen
sure what evil
the ultimate evil legends have it should
be an unimaginable power now she's using
him to regain them
she will not stop until she has remade
our world
into her
[Music]
stay with me okay let's see yourself
you can't run
you can't escape
she's got plans for you
[Music]
[Music]